hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game from the 2013 alejan memorial
it's a ding leading versus levon aronian
you guys have been requesting more and
more ding lyrian games as he is still
trying to qualify for defeated
candidates tournament now i was uh i was
gonna show a game uh from the wei yi
versus dinglin uh match but uh so far
all the five games have ended in a draw
and there are fairly quick draw some 30
moves maybe 33 moves uh there's still
one more more classical game to go and
then they are going um
into thai bricks and there will even be
an armageddon game if needed so we are
gonna get at least one good game uh to
show from that match so no worries there
and also i wanted to inform you guys uh
that uh for those of you who don't know
magnus carlsen is currently playing the
norwegian poker championship and he is
doing very well uh he's on the third day
i believe or maybe even fourth
and he is getting closer and closer to
that final table so uh
a chess aside that we could also be
looking at a new uh maybe uh a
norwegian poker champion if uh you know
everything goes well for him but that's
still
you know uh
a way to go so
we'll see what happens there just
keeping you guys informed now getting
back to this game wonderful game it's uh
from 2013 so from nine years ago uh
let's uh uh see what's happening here
ding has the white pieces and he opens
with d4
uh we have d5 by levon c4c6 going for
the slav defense knight to f3 knight to
f6 and now knight to c3 we have e6 uh
transposing into the semi slav defense
uh or rather sorry not e6 a6 was played
in this game so this is the chameleon
variation of the slav
and dingu goes for e3 we have e6 now and
now uh a pawn all the way to c5 so
whenever this is played we say that this
is a bit of an anti-positional idea but
those ideas uh you know positional ideas
were meant to be broken and hence people
still play unpositional ideas uh so what
this means is that the ning abandons his
very strong center he pushed or maybe
over advances the pawn to c5 and then it
will be very easy for lebron to
undermine the pawn later on with moves
like b6 okay b4 a5 and so on uh so
knight b to d7 first being advances the
pawn to b4 and now we start challenging
this with b6 and the interesting thing
about this position is that uh even
today uh
the engines in 2020 do consider levon's
move to be the strongest but very few
people actually play this people just
play g6 as b6 seems uh
far too complicated but levon doesn't
shy away from all the action bishop to
b2 and now a5 so we are trying to
undermine ding's over advanced structure
here we have a3 and now bishop to e7 we
have bishop to d3 being continuous
development and both players castle so
castles castles and now bishop to a6 uh
attacking the light square bishop as
this will be a very strong attacker so
uh you might consider trading it off uh
and here we have knight to e1 uh saying
that okay if you capture i'm gonna
capture with my knight and then i'm
gonna re-maneuver it to a bit of a more
active square and there is a game even
from 2014 so a year after this game was
played from hot uh between harika navali
and antoinetta stefanova uh where uh e5
was played but here in this game bishop
to c4 is played by levon and it is now
as of move 12 that this position has
never been repeated again uh soding
captures the bishop and why not you get
to double black spawns uh captures
captures and now plays queen to e2 and
at some point of course you will play e4
you will grab the strong center
and it seems that levon did not
succeed in
undermining ding's
flank attack on the queen side so here
rook the b8 the problem with uh okay
your c4 pawn is
hanging but if you defend it with b5
we're just going to play e4 and after
something like captures capture so we
can trade everything off captures
captures uh it's still a better position
for white so the one doesn't want to
play this you have a you have this very
very weak c6 pawn and it's it's not a
position you want to
uh
you want to have against anyone so after
queen to e2 we have rook to b8 now you
have to be careful our queen captures
here we might open up the position that
bishop on b2 could hang
so rook to a to ding defends it uh rook
to b1 also defends the bishop nicely for
some reason ding uh plays rook to e2 a2
and now we have b5 defending the pawn
this way uh e4 and now rook to b7 we
have knights to c2 now uh knights to b8
and now we have rook a back to a1
shifting the rook over to the d file so
queen to c8 making room for the f8 rook
to join the game and now rook a to d1
and now rook to d8 so now levon will go
after the
uh the the d4 pawn and claim that uh
well
you're just not going to be able to hang
on to that pawn uh so here we have
bishop to c1 we have to shift the bishop
to this diagonal as on b2 it really
isn't doing all that much knight to a6
and now bishop to f4 we have rook b to
d7 now putting more pressure on the d4
pawn and h3 taking away the the g4
square from the knight but also if
knight to h5 we can hide the bishop on
h2 so knight back to e8 and now queen to
e3 adding more defenders to the d4 pawn
and levon brings more attackers to the
to the d4 pawn uh and here uh ding could
continue with uh uh well with a variety
of moves but he chooses to go for e5 now
it's a weird move to play uh because you
uh get to this very very weak d for pawn
the d5 uh square has been weak and you
no longer control it with your e4 pawn
however you do gain the e4 square for
your knight so that's very very
important okay bishop back to e7 and now
knight to e4 so can ding make something
of this position uh knight a to c7 now
it's time to get this knight back into
the game and then now knight to d6 here
you could also just create a pass pawn
here which is uh which is very nice but
uh who could resist playing this monster
move this knight to d6 idea saying that
okay now if you trade i just pick up
here and then i have a beautiful pass
pawn that is gonna stay there for the
rest of the game so lavon will try um
not capturing this knight for as long as
possible uh so here as the queen is
attacked you have to move the queen
queen to a8 and now comes queen to g3
now with some ideas of maybe putting
pressure on the black king but still uh
you have the possibility of defending
the g7 pawn with the bishop also the
knight is defending so it's not burning
yet uh knight to d5 now attacking the
bishop and now okay not bishop h6
because the bishop f8 is perfectly fine
for black so knight to e3 dean just
starts bringing more pieces into the
game
and now okay you could capture an f4 but
levon goes for knight to c3 he attacks
the rook and if you move the rook to a
silly square the knight e2 check will
pick up the queen so here rook d to e1
we have to play this and now bishop
captures and e6 so he postponed
capturing as long as possible but at
some point we all knew that he will have
to capture this so e captures on the
sixth now being with the monster pass
pawn on d6 and not knights to e4
attacking the queen here while also uh
threatening knights to d2 as the rook on
f1 will definitely be lost so queen to
h4 and now knight to d2 going after the
rook here and now comes uh well
i
couldn't uh really
agree with myself which moment uh to
choose for the pause the video moment so
i've chosen two uh even though i could
have chosen even more there are plenty
of them here but here ding plays the the
very nice knight to d5
and this means that now okay you could
obviously capture the knight but then we
captured this knight and you're never
getting this rook so there's really
nothing better for lavon than to capture
the rook on f1 and he does this knight
captures on f1
knight the b6 now forking the queen and
the rook here queen to a7 but now not
capturing the rook instead we have rook
captures on f1 uh interestingly d5 here
is uh also just uh winning for white but
it's uh i mean
who would play such a move for example
if he captures uh you're gonna play b
captures on a5 and now black is pretty
much without a move you can't save the
knight you can't uh move this rook
because then this rook hangs it's uh
it's a position
where black is pretty much without moves
uh but okay and you can capture the a4
five one if you capture then uh well uh
queen captures on a5 we're just gonna
get king captures on f1 and still not
much has improved here at some point you
will have to play some like real
captures on d6 and it's really really
ugly uh but okay in the actual game rook
captures on f1 was played by ding now
comes knight to f6 uh the knight will
help out with the defense here and now
bishop the e5 threatening to completely
mess up black spawn structure so knight
to d5 attacking that knight on b6 and
now ding traits knight captures on d5
and now e captures on d5 so uh this is
the first pause the video moment of the
game feel free to pause the video and
try to find the only winning move for
ding here
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this only
winning idea and it's not uh an easy one
you you can't just threaten check maybe
we're gonna play f6 rook defends the the
g7 pawn and that's it so this is the
only move bishop captures on g7 and i'm
sure you guys found this as you know
what's coming next so congratulations on
this uh you have to capture if you don't
capture them i mean you just uh you just
have a hole in in in your castle so king
captures on g7 now queen g5 check king
of f8
f6 threatening checkmate as the the pawn
covers the e7 square so king g8 queen to
g5 check i think ding repeated the
position once uh just so he could reach
move 40 maybe it was a time pressure
thing so this is now move 40 uh queen
king goes back to a f8 queen to f6 and
now king to g8 but now uh comes of
course rook to e1 this is the only way
to win and you have to play it very very
precisely and now the threat of course
is we just bring the rook into the
attack and win the game or do we that's
the real question uh here levon plays a
captures on b4 and it's a move that
seems uh rather unnecessary because why
are you capturing a pawn on the other
side of the board when a checkmate is
being threatened but maybe
there's more than meets the eye here uh
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find a winning idea for being here
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on uh solving the
second pause the video moment uh
precisely and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is not rook to
e3 so hope you guys didn't put the rook
on e3 it's actually rook to e5 this is
the move that wins uh the problem is if
you play rook to e3 then we just play
queen captures on a3 that was the idea
behind levon's a capture sun b4 uh and
uh well now you simply don't have a mate
and uh levon would very gladly give up
the queen for this rook as he still has
two rooks and he has uh well an army of
past pawns here so of course after eight
captures on b4 you could also play
capture some b for just cold
cold-bloodedly saying okay you've got
nothing here that's also winning
but rook to e5 is the move that wins the
game so now uh rook to g5 is the threat
of course uh here levon stops this but
now rook to h5 with the threat of queen
captures an h6 followed by queen to h80
checkmate so queen captures an a3 in the
now queen captures h6 threatening queen
h8 checkmate we have f6 guarding some
squares here also freeing up the f7
square for the king but now queen
captures on f6 and he was in this
position on move 46 that levon arghan
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here rook to h8 is the
threat of checkmate and there's really
nothing you can do here if you give one
check king h2 there's no follow-up there
and if you try something like rook to h7
then it's the very simple rook g5 check
and you only have one move that's rook
g7 and of course queen g7 will be
checkmate
uh so yeah uh i hope you guys enjoyed
this it's from 2013 but still a game
that we still didn't show on this
channel and i really really enjoyed the
disposition after uh
uh after knight captures and d5e
captures just bishop captures and g7
it's uh uh it seems like this rook has
uh quite a few moves to come into the
attack but uh the queen being stuck here
on the queen side and the rook is doing
completely nothing here i mean it's just
a wonderful position that shows you how
quality uh you know before quantity uh
wins almost always in chess
uh so yeah and once again i hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
open c smokey doula open c smokey doula
uh down under book usfd efri uh and
zoran khrushchev for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day